hi Sal so tell us a little bit about
your book and the journey that that you
underwent before you start at the Khan
Academy which led you to writing this
book
yeah well the book is well it's it's a
little bit about that journey but really
how that journey kind of informed what
Khan Academy has now become and then how
that could inform what may be classrooms
could become or what learning could
become and not in just like kind of a
pie in the sky kind of way but I know
this is really happening and it really
feels like we're it's kind of this this
inflection point in what's going on in
classrooms you know the this whole
adventure for me started somewhat
actually very inadvertently it was 2004
I was uh I was working as an analyst at
a hedge fund at the time I just gotten
married family from New Orleans visiting
me in Boston after my wedding and it
turned out this one cousin Nadia was was
having trouble twelve years old
I had trouble believing that you know
she extremely bright girl
we shared us an amount of DNA and and
when I when I asked her about her mom
who told me and I asked Nadia about it
and she said oh yeah I'm having trouble
with units and and I said you know you
you you let me tutor you and and I think
she thought I was just bluffing so I
said no we're gonna work this out so she
went back to New Orleans got on the
phone we ended up using some tools on
the internet so that we could see each
other's scrawls initially with the mouse
and then we have these little pen tablet
things and long story short it you know
she went from being a struggling student
to catching up with her class and then
becoming somewhat advanced a student
actually I jerk I became a tiger cousin
at that point I called her school and I
said I really think Nadia needs to be in
the retake a placement exam and they
said who are you I said I'm her cousin
but but you know I then I started
tutoring her brothers and fast forward
two years word got around free tutoring
was happening I was tutoring 10:15
family friends cousins and it was at
that point that a and the firm I was
working for it was a firm but it was my
boss and his dog and me we we moved to
Silicon Valley and I was showing I was
telling a friend about all
the stuff I was doing with my cousin's
and he said well and I was complaining
that it's getting hard to scale I start
a day job you know these all these
students around the country with time
zones and etc etc and he said well why
don't you make some tutorials to come up
on on YouTube and I thought that was a
silly idea and YouTube for cats playing
piano not serious but I gave it a shot
and you know long story short that kind
of started getting a ton of traction
people started looking at it i those
early days I also was working on this
little software tool for my cousin's and
so there was this view that hey maybe
this could be an institution to help
people and so set up as a not-for-profit
and then in 2009 I had trouble focusing
on my day job so Quinton's started doing
kind of coming full time well so tell me
a little bit about the Khan Academy what
is the business model let's start with
the big hairy audacious goal which I
just found very big an audacious and
then the business model that you're your
face bit on yeah so maybe I'll go the
other way around because you know when I
was starting all of this and I was
sitting in the middle of Silicon Valley
I came from a very for-profit reality
there were I have friends who are
venture capitalists hey Sal let's you
know we could fund this and it could be
this double bottom line business or
whatever that means and and there was a
lot of temptation there and there's
nothing wrong with that but there was
this this feeling you know I was getting
all of this emotional reward from these
thank-you letters that people were
sending me and the sense that hey I was
making these simple things for my cousin
and now you know at first tens of
thousands hundreds thousands now
millions of students are using it around
the world
I'd like the stuff to be around in a
hundred years or in five hundred years
and I don't want this you know this
collection of software and content and
this organization I don't want it to
excuse for this mission of being we
reach these people and so you know when
I look at other organizations in the
universe that are able to do that last
many many hopefully centuries and and
stay true to a mission it's it's a
not-for-profit where there is no
ownership it's it's a public it's a
public charity and and so I said well I
should set this up as a not-for-profit
not quite understanding what that is and
I remember when I was doing that initial
paperwork for it the IRS asks you you
know what's your mission and I kind of
thought about it for
maybe three four minutes and I said well
a free world-class education for anyone
anywhere ever want something you could
just say check it's done it's an
aspiration and it was a very delusional
aspiration at the time I was literally
operating out of a closet but but yeah
and so the business models were not a
business we're a 501 C 3 not-for-profit
but we still have to sustain ourselves
and the way we want to because we always
want the learning side of education we
always want that to be free because we
think that's what empowers people it's
primarily Foundation and philanthropist
and driven so far but we are we do think
there are ways to sustain itself in
other ways whether it's licensing
content or who knows what we're starting
to explore that but what we're pretty
true to keeping the content free sure so
how many students are you serving right
now how many instructors can you give me
a sense as to how large profile of
someone who comes to your website yes so
so the organization itself were 36
people so we're still relatively small
but for us it feels huge for me because
last year we were 13 and a year before
that we were one so we've been growing
fast but in this past month we've
reached 7 million students unique
students we've reached a total of 16
million unique as the way you measure
unique students on the web delivered 180
million lessons 700 million problems
have been done on the site and it's you
know it's its students all over the
world it's pretty much every country in
the world has someone has used the Khan
Academy in some way 20,000 teachers as
far as we can tell from our data are
using it with in their classes or with
their cohorts and in some type of way so
it's it's it's it's kind of crazy and I
call it's it's surreal for where it came
from yeah so let's talk a little bit
about how a classroom or a school can
use you with this concept of a flipped
classroom explain that to our viewers
yeah and I'll do two things because this
flipped classroom has somewhat been tied
to Khan Academy and it is an interesting
idea and it is I think a forward step
but part of the whole point of this
whole book was to show people you know
we're not necessarily about the
flip we're actually about pushing the
envelope even further than the flip so
in a flip model you know right now at
home you do problems traditionally
that's called homework and in the
classroom a lot of time in a traditional
classroom is spent lectures and the the
flip is an it predates Khan Academy
early on I had these videos out there
some teachers were telling me yeah you
made a decent video on meiosis or on you
know projectile motion I don't have to
give that lecture anymore my students
been watching at their own time and pace
they can remediate without Tate you know
taking up class time and then when they
go to class that's when they can either
ask me questions clarifications and we
can do problems together so it used to
be homework the problem sets could now
be done inside the classroom and and the
advantage there is the real learning
occurs when you do the engagement when
you're doing the problem sets and I
think traditionally students either
don't do homework or have trouble doing
homework because there's no one at home
to help them out now they're in the
classroom they have the teacher they
have their peers which is an
underutilized resource and in the
classroom not only to help you but when
you help others you learn a lot better
and and it also gives the teacher lens
on how the class is doing when you're
lecturing it's very hard to know where
people are I mean you might be able to
pull them ask a few questions but it's
very hard a lot of times the students
are a little bit you know blank faces
but now if you're doing problem-solving
together you can do much more you can
understand where students are and
diagnose them and so that's the flip
it's what it used to be homework in the
classroom what used to be lectures are
now at home it makes a classroom
interactive students can get lectures at
their time and pace great what what I on
a lot in the book is let's go even
further because still even the flip
assumes that all the students are going
to cover the same material at the same
pace together and what I talk a lot
about is this you know we've all been
indoctrinated in in the system and when
I talk about the system I'm not talking
about you know what should be the
student-teacher ratio or what you know
charter a private or public I'm talking
about the system I'm talking about
grouping kids by age based cohorts they
cover certain subjects at a set pace we
grade them based on their very
understanding and then we keep pushing
them forward and we just assumed that's
what school is but what I go through
great lengths to shows no this is
actually a relatively new phenomenon
it's about 200 years I'm it's not that
news to 200 200 years old but we
inherited from a country that no longer
exists the Prussians and you know in
fairness to the Prussians and and even
to to us I guess you know it was this
during the Industrial Revolution was the
first time that people seriously thought
about how can we educate everybody
before that it was you know you're the
son of a you know a lord and you would
get a king and you'd get a private tutor
and and the private tutor was the gold
standard it was you know they're there
working at your pace they're
differentiating it for you but now all
of a sudden even pressure there's like
okay we want to have mass education how
do we do it in in a in a practical way
as well it's the Industrial Revolution
well how do we do anything in a
practical way we stick them on an
assembly line and as we they go through
we kind of do something to the product
and then hopefully at the end we have a
decent product and so they essentially
applied the same model to classrooms the
kids are in these buckets based on age
you know it's funny I was talking to a
friend and her child is already knows
how to read and everything and she was
trying to get the child into the
kindergarten you know he's like born in
October or something and and and and the
school said oh yeah and he's very bright
kid but no we can't he's he's too small
and I told my friend she came back he's
like yeah he's too small I was like look
if that's what they were concerned about
they should be grouping them by size
natural but but so that's the model and
so what and even the flip is in the
context of that model you have you know
on week three we cover parabolas week
four we cover systems of equations and
even if you have a we give students
grades we call them we give them a B and
that B shows that they have a gap in
their knowledge a C you know D you can
get on an exam but then you move to the
next topic that's usually building on
top of that which is pretty much dooming
you to failure exact and so what I
advocate strongly and we're already
seeing this in school start an
experiment or move in this direction is
if you take lecture out of the classroom
there's no longer the need for everyone
to move together at the same pace and as
soon as you make get rid of that
assumption you can completely rethink
what a classroom can be
you can start having everyone at their
own pace you can leverage class time
when humans are together for actual
interactivity you can start to say well
why do we only have one teacher in the
room why can't we have two teachers in
the room why do we have a bell rings
bell ringing this is like a factory you
know and you know in 19th century
factory why do we have a bell ringing
that's saying stop what you were doing
on chemistry you must now start English
and we all know anyone who's done
anything creative is that's the best way
to stop creativity is to say you have
exactly 55 minutes and then we're done
and so what what we're advocating is
move to reality with possibly with the
help of tools like Khan Academy so that
everything can learn at their own pace
teachers have dashboards tools that
empower them and that use class time for
interactivity and creativity right right
you touched on this a little bit but
explain a little bit about why is it
that your platform has taken off and is
getting so much attention when so many
others who are kind of trying to do the
same thing on the for-profit side some
on the nonprofit side haven't succeeded
yes it's an open question it's a
question that we were constantly asking
ourselves because we don't whatever the
secret sauce is we don't want to lose it
somewhere in the process
my my best guess of why there was this
initial wave of traction
you know from 2006 to 2008 continues to
grow is those first videos I think it
was fortunate that it was just some guy
making it for his cousin's
I think easy-to-use they're easy to use
they felt very human and I think the big
learning is is that people were hungry
you know I wasn't the first person to
make videos on YouTube I wasn't the
first person to think of teach D you
know people as soon as radio came out
people saying oh we'll use this to teach
the world and then TV oh we'll use this
to teach the world and VCR now it's on
demand but historically it was either a
videotape of someone at a chalkboard you
know traditional class which feels very
it feels distant even when you're in the
classroom you know you're there I'm over
here the next step in the equation and
you do it like that and so that's very
varied and when you make that in the
video it's even harder to see you know
what are they what
writing there and I can't hear them and
and these felt very personal they you're
sitting next to me I think the the other
the other dimension of it it's just the
conversational tone it's you know I
think a lot of people they they they try
to make it very polished which is which
is not bad but in that process you lose
the humanity so it sounds like your GPS
system you know the next situation is
when and and I think hopefully I this is
something that I tried to put into it is
one of the things that I think allowed
me to do to kind of thrive in math or
science and then eventually even finance
was I felt like I had a really holistic
understanding of things and my basics
were really really really solid and then
you know my basics in algebra were
really good so when I went into calculus
I know this is intuitive and when I went
into you know corporate finance I was
like oh this is intuitive there's
nothing new here and and and you see
other really really smart people they're
they're just learning for the next exam
memorizing formulas then they forget it
and then when they see a related concept
it's like what's this and so what I
tried in those early days for my
cousin's is give a sense of intuition
draw the connections between things so
that when they see this new concept it's
not something random new concept it's
connected to everything they learned
before and and and I and I get a lot of
letters and I would have assumed that
that would have only been appealing to
you know the motivated kids so to speak
but I get a lot of letters from kids
that were traditionally disengaged or
demotivated and they said that's why I
was demotivated no one was explaining
the why well no one was giving me the
the connection so hopefully that that's
why people are have been I guess
connecting to the to the content yeah so
let's talk a little bit about virtual
education and offering the types of
things that you're offering a lot of
people are still a little wary of of
these reforms they see it as a mechanism
to ultimately get rid of teachers in the
classroom or reduce class sizes you
talked a little bit about this in the
book and explain that a little bit yeah
yeah I think that's a super important
point because whenever you know when
we've learned in the last 15 20 years of
the internet whenever people see virtual
it's like is that going to replace the
physical you know Barnes and Nobles
versus amazon.com there's a natural
contention there that's exact opposite
of what I think is going to happen in
education
everything we do is not going to replace
a physical school I have young kids I
want them to go to a physical school I
want them to get interaction what it
will do is I think give all of our
children the experience that I think
every parent and every teacher or every
student wants to be a part of and then
even now we're going to a physical
experience but we're not leveraging the
humans we're going and but for the most
part people are sitting passively there
and they're listening and it's hard for
the teachers too because you're not it's
it's it's hard to just speak for for 60
minutes without getting that connection
with the students and so what we're
advocating is leverage tools so you can
get maybe information delivery out of
the way so you can get some of the
problem-solving out of the way but so
when people go and they have class time
the scarce class time with other human
beings and that's optimally interactive
and not interactive in the web sense
interactive in the human sense so class
time is all conversation class time is
all peer tutoring and working with the
teacher class time is all doing
open-ended projects and so you know I
talked about this in the book and I gave
a TED talk a bunch you know the irony
here is I strongly believe and it's not
just talk again you know we're seeing
this in classrooms is that you can
actually use technology to make the
classroom more human and I'm very
careful I you know you mentioned there's
skepticism I think there should be I'm
skeptical when someone says hey we just
ordered 500 iPad for our school and I
said well what are you gonna do with it
or how are you going to integrate into
curriculum or how are you going to
leverage it to make to fundamentally
transform what's going on and they're
usually aren't a lot of answers there
and so I think it is good to be
skeptical but at the same time there is
I think a reason reason reason for hope
and so how do you evaluate the impact of
your courses since again you talk a
little bit about grades in your book and
how you don't like the concept of
grading how do you know that they have
actually worked yeah and I'll tell you
and you know a lot of times when I grew
up I remember I sometimes would meet
people said I don't believe in grades
and I thought they were these kind of
like you know granola bar and hippie
type people that you know and and now I
think I appreciate what they were saying
grades you know normally when you say
people people who don't like grades you
really think that they're being
touchy-feely they're not being rigorous
but actually they're being they're
saying grades aren't rigorous enough
grades are this thing that give this the
of rigor Oh a B a so you really know
your stuff f you don't know your stuff
one there they're somewhat arbitrary you
know depends on the test depends on how
its measured but but even more than that
when you give grades especially in the
sense if you if you got to see on an
exam you have obvious weaknesses
assuming that it was given a good exam
you have obvious weaknesses and so that
should be used in us as an assessment to
say okay you need to now improve on
those weaknesses before we move on to a
more advanced topic look it's common
sense get your basics down but instead
we use grades as a value judgment you're
smart you're dumb you're fast you're
slow and that's that's a good that's
just going to be a self-fulfilling
prophecy so what we say is no let's just
make sure everyone masters every concept
so rather than having a superficial
understanding of algebra and then moving
over on to trigonometry make sure you
really understand algebra deeply and
then trigonometry is going to make a lot
more sense it's going to be a lot easier
to learn and if your master manometry
than calculus is going to start seeing
me seeing seeming very intuitive in
terms of how we're doing it we're
working with schools and famously Los
Altos which is now using Khan Academy
units it's probably one of the best if
not the best you know School District in
the country is is using Khan Academy for
fifth through eighth grade as part of
their as one of the tools that they use
and there we have formal studies going
on to understand exactly how this is
impacting students and teachers both
objectively on things like test scores
and grades but also on things on
subjectively are the teachers more
excited about their work are the
students more excited about about their
work and then on top of that you know we
have three million problems done a day
on our site we have this huge number of
students seven million a month using our
set so we have this treasure trove of
data on our site itself and so we are
building an app other web companies are
able to do we as a kind of Education
not-for-profit can now do using
analytics optimizing for engagement
seeing what kind of learning is going on
so tell me a little bit about so you you
gave a great historical overview of how
we came to educate students today the
way we're educating them did you always
hold these views and know this
information before you stumble
the Khan Academy or the this platform
that you created or were these things
that you you know studied afterwards it
just so happens that everything flows so
beautiful you know it it's been a
combination I actually think it's more
of the latter you know obviously all of
us have spent a lot of time in the
system I think the whole time you know
anybody who knew me growing up I mean
they knew that I was always like why is
this this way why is this that way wait
why why can't I tutor you know I I
should get reprimanded for trying to
tutor my I don't know why this this is
sort of a really positive interaction
and so there's this question you know
and then you go to college and you're
like while people are sitting in this
lecture hall is anything really
happening in here it seems like all the
learning is happening when they're the
cram session you know three days before
the final and and so there was always
these ideas and then obviously when I
started working with my cousin's I
started seeing that my cousin's were
motivated they were for the most part
good students but they were having these
huge gaps in their knowledge they
weren't learning things intuitively so I
invariably started building these tools
and it was really a process of discovery
of teachers emailing me saying hey we're
using it this way we're using it that
way and so it's a combination of these
instincts of like well how did I learn
how do other people I know who learn
things holistically how did they learn
what am I seeing with my teacher with my
with my cousin's what our teachers
telling me and then it's kind of kind of
me got more and more traction I started
having people tell me about a lot of the
stuff I mean I knew a little bit about
the history before you know I've heard
about this whole you know committee of
10 and 99 you know someone had told me
about that in high school but but it was
interesting that and you know even the
research I the original reason why I
made the videos so short is because
YouTube limited me to 10 minutes but
then I used to have researchers time you
know there's actually cognitive research
that shows and that's what you know
that's where a lot of that research from
the book comes from that like actually
people for especially dense academic
content can't pay attention for more
than 10 to 15 minutes and so it starts
as Wow so why are we doing these you
know why are we using class time this
time with human beings for these
hour-long lectures or sometimes 90
minute lectures can't we get people to
interact more and you know the more I
did research a lot of these kind of just
basic common-sense ideas gelled with
research and that's what you feel best
about it because they are common every
it it's weird when research tells you
something very non and
but here's telling you something very
very very intuitive and the only the
only kind of hard to graph thing is that
we're indoctrinated into a strange model
right right it all makes sense so tell
me a little bit about your own education
I mean something despite the regimented
system that you grew up in something
must have gone right was it a teacher
was it your parents you think who kind
of built this sense of inquisitiveness
and or was it yeah was did you go to a
particular type of school that was open
to nurturing you as an individual and
paying attention to your specific needs
or yeah none of these things well yeah
no no I mean I delusional
although I am sometimes delusional and I
would say that if none of that stuff
played in I mean I think there was
probably two I mean there's probably a
bunch of different factors and I'm
probably forgetting some of them while I
was blessed to have an older sister who
was a very good student so I think that
projected when I would walk into a
classroom the teachers would remember my
sister I said oh you're fair assist but
you're Ferris brother you must be and I
was like you know I was like it speech
therapy but they would they would
project that and you know there's
actually now studies that show that that
projection has huge implications for
your own self-esteem so that was luck on
top of that I you know I went to a just
a out take it was a public school in
Jefferson Parish public schools in
Jefferson Parish right outside of New
Orleans I would say was the average
American public schools all of them you
know middle elementary middle and high
school but you know there were some
incredible teachers there I think in in
high school in particular mr. Hernandez
miss Kennedy and miss Kennedy was the
journalism teacher and actually I would
say that's where a lot of the ideas that
look class should not be a lecture class
should be working alongside the teacher
was journalism class so we were we had a
product a creative product and use paper
to work on I was the art editor and she
would give us feedback and she was like
our senior peer and I and I remember
those interactions and a lot of the
experience that I got from journalism I
still think about when I'm when I when
I'm working on Khan Academy I think
early in my schooling I think this was
key and also lucky I I got into you know
I don't know what they call it now is GT
programs and what they did is now you
have this very structured Prussian
curriculum for most of the day but then
one day week they take you out of a
different classroom and they
- these GT classrooms and there you go
into this classroom which is essentially
the kind of classroom that ideally
everyone should have where you have this
real it was actually Miss Rochelle and
miss Kraus these two teachers and they
you know they had PhDs in education and
and they I remember the first day
walking into GT and Mistress Elsa so
what do you want to do and I was like
eight mm-hm
I like to draw and then she says well
you should draw more then and then what
you would introduce me to these things
different styles different tools to draw
what else are you interested in and I
was like I like puzzles and she's like
well here's some puzzle that she would
give me these brain teasers but and so
she was mentoring me and it was
self-paced and I was able to go to my
own pace and there was other kids
working on interesting things and I
would get inspired by them sometimes we
work on things and I think we needed
that breathing room to have I wonder if
I didn't have that experience early on
in my life whether I would have had the
ability to kind of self direct or or had
the ability to can say oh but let me
solve that problem no one you know that
that's an interesting thing to tackle
right so along those lines do you have
any advice for parents out there you
know first graders second graders and
I'm asking you this because in your book
you also highlight how a lot of students
in Southeast Asia go to school in order
to show off what they know not
necessarily to learn in school so are
there habits that you think parents can
start to you know put in place early on
a despite how the schools are
approaching education yeah and you know
take everything I say with a grain of
salt I have a three-year-old and a
one-year-old so maybe I should getting
advice from the parents I'm trying to
get my one-year-old off of a pacifier
absolutely right I mean my sense having
kind of gone through the system and even
we're observing we're working with a lot
of teachers we're working a lot of
schools now I would say there's a couple
of dimensions here I think it is true
Asians whether it's East Asian South
Asian they there is a culture of school
is where you go to show what you've
already learned at home and I think that
gives those students an advantage of
having this kind of buffer of their
learning stuff maybe ahead and and I'm
not saying that necessarily has to be
the way but that is a way to ensure that
your student in the
Prussian model doesn't get you know
falls behind and as soon as they fall
behind all of these negative kind of
self perception things and they start to
reinforce each other well so I would do
I mean I'll tell you what I would do
with my own children I would do some
combination of engaging them with a lot
of the content in a way before it
becomes stressful so you teach it when
you tutor when I was teaching Nadia
algebra when she was an algebra class it
was stressful for her because she's
fighting to catch up I have an exam on
it when I started teaching algebra to
her younger brother who's in fifth grade
he thought it was fun
because there's no stress here it was
just a fun thing his cousin was teaching
so at least expose your kids to the
ideas in algebra and physics and biology
and chemistry early on so that when they
see it in school they've already they've
already had some exposure the other
thing I would say is don't over schedule
them I mean I think sometimes the same
parents that would you know the same
parents that would do the teaching ahead
of time at the same time will also know
you have piano lessons you have soccer
lessons you have everything and I think
there's a value there definitely but if
it's complete over scheduling you have
the loss of time for the child to
develop their own creativity kind of
what I had in that GT class so you know
frankly you know the needs I was a
latchkey child where my mom was you know
she worked these odd jobs and would come
home at 6 or 7 o'clock and so me and my
sister would just hang out and yeah some
of it was wasted watching TV but a lot
of it was just like I want to build
something or I want to draw her we would
like make make up games and stuff like
that and kids need that they need that
free space and maybe if they're blowing
it all on video games or watching TV you
need to push them a little bit too or or
do something creative with them but they
need that time for creativity and though
the last thing I would actually
recommend is that the parents themselves
engage in learning you set that example
if you're 40 or 50 years old and you're
going back and learning algebra or
cosmology or English Lit it's a it's a
huge signal for students so let's talk
about your vision for the ideal
classroom or the this futuristic vision
that you outline here about what the
school of tomorrow should look like
which is a lifelong learning approach to
education I mean you also talk about the
college of tomorrow to look like it
would I was fascinated by this but let's
talk just about schooling your notions
of class size the ideal classroom could
potentially have
hundred students entered with for
instructors roaming around and helping
students you talked a little bit about
grades already but testing this is one
of those topics that comes up a lot here
in Washington and put the discussions on
Capitol Hill but yeah how would you you
know describe that vision for us and you
also talked about how you would get rid
of summer vacations which is ya know
there's a lot there I mean you know the
first dimension is once you remove
lecture from class time you see class
time is a time for interaction you could
have students working at their own pace
allows you to rethink everything and so
a lot of the concepts in this book and a
lot of these are happening I mean
there's schools that we're working with
that are doing these things these are
there they are experiments for their
experiments that all the research and
all of the intuition point in that
direction teaching is for the most part
of solitary profession you're the only
teacher in the room it's lonely it's
lonely and and so you could have a
hundred students you're not changing the
student-teacher ratio you might even
improve it but you're not enough for
teachers in the same room now if one of
them gets sick students don't have a
substitute teacher different students
are gonna connect with different
teachers they can mentor each other they
can do group things with teachers
together but there's there's a whole
dimension that you can add you could
have a physics teacher a math teacher a
chemistry teacher and a biology teacher
all teaching simultaneously so students
understand that all these Sciences in
these math actually blend together
they're not these like siloed subjects
so they get a holistic understanding you
know the tests themselves you need some
aspect of testing but someone should be
you should be very skeptical of testing
because all tests measure what they test
and and and there's many more facets to
to a human being than that and so the
dimensions that you know there could be
some testing to make sure that students
are getting core competency and some
core skills but the more important
skills which I think are completely
unmeasured right now are creativity and
you can ever give someone else
creativity score but you can't have
someone generate generate a portfolio of
creative works I mean you know we as an
employer we're hiring engineers and when
we get these people great GPAs from top
schools in the country and we say so
what have you created
that's what engineering is building new
things
and they haven't created anything
because they've been on the treadmill
the whole time just trying to finish
problem sets and they're very very smart
people and so the ideal is is that
students over their careers can show
what they've created it's not like they
can write a paper it gets graded and
gets thrown away they write a paper
maybe it gets graded and then they keep
working on the paper they keep
developing it when they're 18 they have
a novel done they have a bunch of papers
on policy done then they can show people
this is my work they have computer
programs written they build robots and
on top of that and this is another
dimension that's completely missed in in
the in the Prussian model so to speak is
as I think in any field the people you
want to work with the most are the
people who have deep subject matter
expertise and but are also always
willing to help others and they have
that communication and that ability to
empathize and in our in our current
system we make everyone very focused on
themselves what are your grades are you
going to pass a test cram for the next
exam and in the model that we're
describing we're starting to see in a
lot of schools let's focus everyone on
on each other so yeah you go at your own
pace you might be racing ahead and
that's great you know you're stimulated
you're engaged but you also have a
chance to re-engage with some students
who might be having difficulty and
there's two things one you're going to
be helping that student but even better
when you explain that hopefully and you
develop your ability to explain you'll
learn the material better and you'll
learn to communicate you'll learn to
empathize and that actually is
measurable I mean you can you can have
students rate each other you can have
people write assessments for each other
oh you know he understood the stuff but
he was a little bit you know he spoke a
little fast and you could develop that
aspect and so I'd imagine the transcript
of the future and I say the future what
I mean the future is like actually now
is yeah you would have your test scores
your test scores would actually show
actual competency it wouldn't be grades
it would be like yeah I understand
algebra and I've renewed it right I've
renewed that I know algebra well I know
cosmology I'm I'm a writer here's and
here's my writings you have a portfolio
of your creative works in
multi-dimensions and you have reviews
from people that you've helped saying
great person to work with really
understood the subject matter really was
able to communicate well and and those
are the things that I think anyone would
actually care about more than than just
test scores right but let's talk a
little bit about what happens in this
classroom or school
in terms of subjects so you believe that
so right now there's you know you have
to take math you have to take English
language arts you know you start science
at a certain point in time do you I mean
do you believe that all these basics
should also be thought in the school and
at what point I mean another question I
wanted to ask is do I mean do you
believe that all children can learn
unless they have a serious disability
can they all progress to the levels that
you have progressed to if they simply
learn and master and show an interest
really in the in the subject matter that
they are that that they're studying and
specifically these Aveda STEM fields
science technology engineering and math
which are areas that kids tend not to
get interested in is it just because
they haven't mastered it well and been
pushed to understand it early on or are
their limitations perhaps in how we are
currently trying to get students to
learn these subjects yeah so on the
latter question if you ask me 20 years
ago I said yeah maybe certain people are
predisposed to math and science and
other people aren't and and that made me
feel good because I was one of the
people who are predisposed and made me
feel like I was meant to be there wasn't
luck but my experience with my cousin's
Nadia in particular but other cousins
and then what we're seeing in schools
you know the schools that are kind of
transitioning to this type of a model
where all the students are learning at
their own pace building their
foundations we're seeing you know day
five yeah some kids have raced ahead
those well those are the gifted kids and
some kids are falling behind it like all
maybe they need to be remediated and a
traditional model you would separate
them and you would actually tell these
kids you you're smart and you tell these
kids either explicitly or implicitly
you're not not as smart but what we're
seeing is if you keep them together when
you allow them to work at their own pace
so that they're engaged they have
mentorship from each other and and the
teacher many times is it's actually
quite hard to predict we're trying to
produce very hard some of these students
were falling behind
maybe it's an algebra class and they
just some of them didn't know
multiplication well some of them didn't
know how to add fractions you give them
that opportunity to really build that
foundation on negative numbers
multiplication exponents whatever it
might be and then these kids race ahead
so it was not the problem wasn't that
they had some cognitive inability to
understand algebra the problem was
they're sitting in an algebra class and
for some reason they didn't understand
how to multiply or they'd understand how
to add fractions and you just
feel silly in an algebra class and
you'll disengage really just a just to
protect your own self-esteem so I'm
actually now more and more convinced
that pretty much everyone you know
barring certain exceptions could we
don't know where I mean we're still
learning we don't know but progress far
ahead and we're even seeing it you know
in these classrooms we traditionally
think motivated kids maybe that's 20% of
kids but as soon as you allow people to
engage and fill in gaps without feeling
embarrassed you start seeing it's not
twenty percent its eighty or ninety
percent of kids can start to feel
engaged in terms of the first question
about like what subjects and how I think
it is an interesting and I talked a
little bit about it is you know it's the
subjects that are taught now are
somewhat arbitrary they were decided in
1892 by the committee of ten mainly
University a male university presidents
who did not know about you know this was
before the Federal Reserve existed the
interstate highways existed knowledge of
DNA and you know a bunch of other stuff
and they decided that you know at age
fourteen you should learn algebra at age
fifteen you should learn geometry at age
sixteen you should learn trigonometry so
unusual in physics your senior year in
high school you should learn I mean
that's when it was decided and it hasn't
changed since and I love all of those
subjects I think they're all fascinating
but III think there are obvious
questions you know should there be more
statistics it statistics more valuable
than characters or at least as valuable
should there be some knowledge of
economics who knows gonna be I mean I
won't it's for society to decide but the
general idea is at minimum it should be
rethought within the last hundred and
twenty years there is grounds the world
has changed we should think more about
what these subjects are and and even
more I think you know and you alluded to
this should they even be divvied up in
these siloed subjects these siloed
subjects these are we're indoctrinated
into it so it's hard for us to break our
minds from it this is the factory model
this is oh you're at this you're at this
machine in the factory and so this is
what will be poured into the product
okay now you're gonna have the paint
applied to you now so now you're gonna
have the chemistry applied to you now
you move on now you're going and for
some people that might tip a little bit
that's fine that'll be a cheaper product
at the end but the reality is these I
mean chemistry is halfway in between
Kemp physics and biology and physics is
halfway in between
chemistry and and pure mathematics and
all of them actually have an aspect of
philosophy to them all of them have an
aspect of aesthetics to them and and
whatever else and writing can be
critical and logical thinking is is
across all programs you know you could
have something like a logic which is
across everything and and so I I think
the reality we're moving to is yes you
will show competency in things say yeah
I I understand this domain well so you
can go take an exam and then renew that
exam to show that yes I still understand
that topic but while you're in school
some will might be preparation for that
particular competency but most of the
time we'll be blending it where you're
where you're not you're not working to
pass an assessment you're working to
create things and so in the process of
creating things whether it might be a
novel or robot or a business you're
integrating all of these things I mean
anyone who started a business if sharing
a tech business is there's a cop there's
art design there's technology there's
quantitative thinking and there's
writing and there's just human skills
and you need to integrate it that's what
actually matters in the real world and
so these when you break yourself from
this assembly line model you give
yourself the freedom for people to
pursue these type of things so why not
create a Khan Academy charter school or
even the Khan Academy private school yes
we go back and forth on that but I it's
we're thinking about it we're thinking
about it I mean I'd you put it which
country would you pick - well for
selfish reasons I would probably put it
in Mountain View California walking
distance from no but seriously I think
you know it's interesting because and
this shows the emphasis we put I think a
physical experience is incredibly
incredibly important you know a lot of
people in Silicon Valley say well you're
at scale already you're reaching 7
million and you're growing you're
doubling every year you could reach 100
million students in five years maybe a
billion in your and and you know why are
you even thinking about the physical or
why are you thinking about physical
schools and I always say it well that's
because that's the core that's and I
also think you need you might say well
why I focus on one school that might be
able to reach a few hundred kids when
you're when you're able to reach 100
maybe one day and and the idea is if you
can show examples of this and there are
schools that have already moved in that
direction Los Altos has moved in that
direction summit prep which is a charter
school they've broken down walls they
have multiple teachers teaching classes
in these kind of epic environments if
you show examples of this then I think
that that's what moves that's what moves
the dial forward so how much would be
the session the tuition you know looking
at a Venusian New York forty thousand a
child without this book and vision the
money is is fascinating you know
education is is you know someone asked
me recently is it can you ever spend too
much on education and to some of you the
answer's no I mean it's such an
important thing but at the same time if
you're going to spend that much money
you have to think seriously about how
you're spending it and I've met with
some you know officials about this and a
public level parter of private schools
and I just - regardless of school I say
how much do you spend per pupil per year
here ask a private school some of them
you know 25,000 30,000 40,000 a year you
ask a public school you know the the
some states it's as low it goes down to
five six thousand dollars a year but
most states especially on the East Coast
it's ten fifteen thousand New York City
public schools eighteen thousand year
Cambridge Massachusetts twenty-five
thousand dollars per year per student
and I say okay and what's your average
class size and they'll usually say some
number between twenty and thirty and I
said okay private school you're charging
thirty thousand a year there's twenty
students that's six hundred thousand
dollars per classroom that's essentially
for the tea you know what what's
directly impacting the students the
teacher the classrooms and maybe the
textbook all I can figure out is maybe
there's a hundred thousand 150,000 being
spent there where is the other quarter
of a million or three hundred thousand
dollars
same thing at any level why can't we
instead use hat we can low you know the
private school I think for ten thousand
to forty thousand ten thousand a year
you have twenty students or let's say
you have thirty students in a class
that's three hundred thousand dollars a
year
I say pay the teacher 150 thousand make
teaching you know a lot of people pay
lip-service to oh we should you know
teaching should be on par with doctors
and engineers and lawyers as the way
that's nice lip service but if you
they believe that pay teacher is the
same as doctors engineers and lawyers
that's the best signal to society that
you actually value it and but the money
is clearly there and and then it'll have
to get cut from all the stuff that's not
impacting the students all of the I
don't know you know the back I don't
know every time I ask this to people I
just do this back of the envelope
calculation this is what I used to do in
my old career nice to speak to CFO's say
oh you're making this - what am I
missing and a same exact question you
know fifteen thousand a year times
thirty students is four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year the fully
loaded cost of the teacher is less than
half of that plus the C where where's
that money going and and so I think you
could do a very good model for what what
public schools are spending definitely
some of the more you know the schools
the systems are spending ten thousand
dollars plus so talked a little bit
about how Bill Gates came to discover
you and and I just thought that chapter
was so interesting and yeah I mean what
was it like to find out all of a sudden
that Bill Gates was watching your videos
and I still wake up in the morning
sometimes wondering whether that was all
like made up or a dream it's you know
the site had already gotten traction but
at summer of 2010 one of our first door
donors and door sent me started telling
me text messages that Bill Gates was at
the Aspen ideas festival telling the
whole audience that he uses a site that
he thinks is great called the Khan
Academy and he uses it with his kids and
he uses it himself which made me a
little nervous cuz I mostly just for
Nadia but then um you know and and I
didn't know what to do I said do I reach
out to him I mean I don't think he's
listed or if he's uh but then his uh two
weeks later chief of staff called and
said you know you might have heard bill
bills a fan yeah
and they they said you know if you're
free we'd like to fly you up and I also
get my calendar was completely blank I
could make some time for Bill you know
I've got to cut my nails but other than
that and I I went up and I mean really
articulated this look you know at the
time it was mainly the videos I was
doing I was like look if we could get
some resources and I was dreaming about
a five person team in some office space
that wasn't the dream at that point we
could make we could build out the
software that I
started doing with my cousin's so
students can get practice they can get
feedback we can start building a
community on the site so the students
can help each other we can build
dashboards for teachers so that they
could use it to diagnose students and
leverage class time more effectively and
and him and then a later Google as well
you know they they were they were on
Glee great so you know you talked a
little bit about talent and creativity
in your book and we talked a little bit
about this earlier on but do you think
you know in the advent of all these are
not advent but since you know a couple
years ago there were books focused on
talent talent is overrated the talent
code do you name it so and I've read all
of those I have a seven year old who I'm
trying to foster into a talented
individual do you think talent and
creativity are things that can be in
fact you know taught to children or are
they there I'm not sure and frankly and
I think any and I think anyway I'm Frank
I think no one is sure I my sense
through both observation and just even
seeing what what's happening there it
it's not something that's taught but
it's something that can be untaught it's
not something that it's it's it's not
and it's it's it can it can be fostered
or it can be suppressed
both talent and creativity and and I
actually think probably all I think
everyone is born with creativity I mean
there's not a two-year-old on the planet
who if you introduce a new object into
the room will not walk up to that object
and manipulate it in every way taste it
feel it see what they can do with it
pour something there's not a
two-year-old on the planet there's not a
five-year-old actually most
five-year-olds well still a new object
in the room they will engage with it a
new idea they'll ask questions about it
but then something happens where they
they're taught to become more passive to
some degree they are an environment
where questioning is not always cool
they they're so overwhelmed with work
whether it's soccer practice or homework
that there's no time for them to kind of
just think about something you know the
class is moving on they can't think
about wait why am i why am i carrying
the one why does that make sense it
seems it's just like a formula to me
they don't have time for that type of
stuff and so the you know all of these
things fall from this idea of just
breaking from this Prussian model
breaking from this one piece
it's electric as soon as you take that
out now all of a sudden you can start
saying hey why can't we let a student
you know right now there's a if there's
a 16 year old someplace in the country
who has just some insight I'm like well
maybe cancer can be addressed in maybe
maybe this is what cancer is and too bad
the clap the Bell's gonna ring or they
have an AP test the next day or they
have an exam like oh well - I have too
much work to do I have you know there I
quote an admissions officer in the book
talked about she was interviewing a
bunch of people who are coming to a very
elite college and said you know what are
you daydream about and the one student
said we don't need dream about anything
because it doesn't help us to get into
college and and you know that's tragic
it's tried to catch me for that child
but it's tragic for society because it's
those daydreams that eventually lead to
actual I'll take you know Khan Academy
exists to a large degree because my my
boss at the hedge fund in a very
non-traditional for that field had a
strong belief in life work about an
imbalance and so I had time to daydream
about the Khan Academy I had time I had
and my wife was a resident medical
resident so I I felt bad sitting in
vegging and watching TV and so I was
able to think about this this problem
and make resources and we and I think
anyone is capable of doing that we just
have to give them the time and the
breathing room to do it especially now
since it appears I don't know if this
was in your book or I heard it from Tom
Friedman I mean most of the jobs of
tomorrow are going to be jobs that are
going to be created not jobs that
currently exist you know if you go near
the Prussian model exist arted the
Industrial Revolution and the Industrial
Revolution we needed probably more
educated people than we needed in kind
of an agrarian civilization you need
people who could like read the
directions and have the discipline of
the assembly line and all of that but
there was also there was a certain
passivity that you also had to implicate
you know in the farm there's a certain
independence and freedom to it all of a
sudden a factory you're doing this over
and over again and you know and even we
one can debate whether it was explicitly
done but there was an element of
instilling that passivity an
indoctrination so that people could be
good workers but now we're in the rail
you know before the pyramid was like
this you needed a few knowledge workers
who are doing creative things and then
you needed a mass
of Labor now the pyramid is kind of
inverted where you we need a lot of
creative people in fact all of the real
careers in our or creative focused and
and open-ended and you need very few you
need very little physical labor and and
in that reality where you know we're
training people for this while we need
you we need the opposite and so since we
are in the nation's capital do you have
any advice for Congress or the president
how can they best help bring this vision
to life
understanding that yeah you know and
this is it's an interesting question
because we do meet with state officials
and federal officials and you know even
in other countries ministries of
Education and the one thing that I don't
want to happen is you know right now
it's been a very grassroots grounded up
thing people have word-of-mouth Khan
Academy people have been using it
parents have been telling parents
teachers have been telling teachers and
that's good because that's way these are
people who want to make it work and they
figure out and they tell us ways to make
it work better as soon as you make it
top-down I think it becomes macum x' no
one likes it anymore
and so we want this to be very
grassroots whatever I tell people is
just just tell people about it tell
people at minimum they have a free tutor
tell teachers that look there might be
another model that you probably will
enjoy more there are ways to reach more
students and on top of that and I'm
serious about this I think if they say
they should set an example it's become
too it's too easy now in our society for
people say oh I'm not good at math and a
little say that about like 6th grade
math oh I don't know that's math I don't
understand it no one will say oh I can't
read it a sixth grade level or I can't I
can barely write no one says that but
people say you'll hear politicians say
that you'll hear CEO say that you'll
hear people in the in the press say that
and I think that messaging should change
and frankly the only way that it could
change is if they directly engage with
it I mean it's it's shocking how many
people are engaged in education policy
where they don't know the subject matter
themselves with like oh I'm a good at
math but this is how we should test math
math teachers it's like that's crazy you
yourself should engage in the content or
get it get a depth in the content and
that'll be a huge signal to society and
I think it'll also help help inform
policy and I think the more they do that
they'll realize that it's a lot less
about top down a lot less about the
controls you know the controls that they
do every iteration of ed reform is just
about more controls on teachers
and it might de-risk some of the the
weaker players but it also handicaps the
all the rest and so it kind of gets to
this kind of culture of you know
everyone getting to mediocre and what we
need to really do is go the other way
have it be much more grassroots and what
I point out in this book that's an
American thing that we're a country
that's focus on creativity we're a
country that's focused on people taking
ownership over their lives but our
school system is a Prussian one well fun
that's about passivity one that's about
authority and everything about this book
is let's make our school system more
American so any final thoughts if you
were sitting with President Obama you
know if the White House aside from
asking him to use his bully pulpit more
I'm somewhat serious about ask him to so
I this is a somewhat different dimension
but we talked about this in the book I
would ask him to make content for us
because I think what's happening right
now is the public discourse gets so
disjointed in these 30-second sound
bites then you can't have a chance to go
deep on either side of the aisle and
right now you know the main adult
learning happens on the 24-hour news and
it's in these 30 seconds so no one
really understands the issues and it
just becomes very emotionally charged
and this form factor this way it's a
chance for Obama to really explain why
he makes the decisions he does and maybe
the opposition to really explain why and
get to an end diagram it out and even
have a quiz afterwards to make sure that
people are retaining it and it would
kind of fill in that gap in learning
that frankly people are creating some of
our most popular videos are about credit
default swaps or the health care plan or
the difference you know the electoral
college these are gaps in people's
learning and adults of any age one
learned that it was a pleasure reading
this book it was nice meeting you thanks
for joining us oh it was a pleasure